In the implementation we are summing up the energy for all points,
which is mass times gravitation acceleration times y position for every point
and the energy for every spring.
The resulting diagram may be regarded as abstract art,
but also shows the evolution of that rope.
We are starting with a random configuration,
but eventually the shape of the rope becomes plausible.
Keep in mind that this is not--I repeat--not temporal evolution,
even though it looks like that.
This shows a path of optimization toward an equilibrium.
We are not talking about forces or acceleration here.
It's a search process, like finding the shortest path to connect 10 cities.